Hello everyone! You are watching
a Business English series brought
to you by British Council English
Online. We’re hoping to equip you
with the practical skills you need to thrive inthe
international, English-speaking workspace.
Today is episode 2 of the conflict
management series. I’m going to
give you practical tips on how to manage
conflict effectively in the workspace.
Click on the little 'i' up here and it
will take you to the first episode.
Alright, we’re going to go
straight in with tip number 3.
Be specific about issue and impact.
When entering into a conversation that is
attempting to manage conflict,
saying things like 'you
always' or 'you never' is never a good idea. Sweeping
statements like these will often result
in a defensive response. And to be honest, Ican understand
why. If someone said to you,
'you always complain' you’d probably think,
'well actually I can think of quite a few
examples and situations where I didn’t.'
You always criticise what I do!
Oh hey! Your presentation
was really well executed.
Yeah that’s really well written.
Be objective and avoid personal attacks.
So, for example, instead of saying
'You always criticize what I do'
You could say:
'I didn’t appreciate it when you criticizedmy work
in front of our partners yesterday
in the meeting at 10am, specifically, 10:32.'
Here you’re pinpointing the pain point.
Pinpoint the pain point.
Apparently, you remember
things more when it becomes a melody.
Remember, be specific about an issue,
and avoid, stay away from generalisations.
Number 4: Don’t bring up past events.
Anybody who has ever been to marriage
counselling, couple counselling,
friend counselling, any kind of counselling
will have heard this advice before.
We often bring up past events as a kind
of trump card hoping it will put us in a
position of power within that conversation.
I just wanted to say that it felt a little
bit condescending yesterday when
you spoke over me in the meeting.
Okay but, you spoke over me in the board meetinglast
year, so now you know what it feels like.
Just because our friend here remembered how their
colleague acted one year ago, doesn’t resolve the
fact that they interrupted them yesterday.
Here’s what we need to do. Take that list from
out of your back pocket, the one where you’venoted
all the things that you didn’t like about
your colleague over the past 2 years. Takethat
list, and tear it up, blow it away.
When you bring up past events, you’re
distracting people from the main point
of the conversation, which doesn’t resolve why
you’re in a conflict in the first place.
See you in episode three for our last 2 tips.
Bye!